welcome back to the rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and the true secret weapon to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe has been the
mind of Tony Stark the way he applied as
many screw-ups and to ingenious upgrades
throughout many generations of tech sure
he's dead
but as I've been spending this
quarantine period in the blue dungeon
mark2 rewatching the Infinity Saga
you started to see the lessons that Tony
learns each movie are subtly applied in
MCU films that come out years later we
talked about some of these applications
with Tony's armor after endgame came out
but even deeper secrets only now being
dredged out of this autopsy you notice
that if you extrapolate this evolution
forward might tell us where the MCU
could go next okay so in my recent read
breakdown at Iron Man check it out I
pointed out how Tony learns that true
change comes from the heart and he takes
away two key lessons from its nemesis in
this film Obadiah Stane first that you
can disable an enemy by going for the
heart Toby doesn't him and in the next
movie Tony disables whiplash in their
first fight in the same exact way but
Obi also tells Tony this there's so many
applications regarding short-term
paralysis
Tony will reapply this lesson against
Thanos on Titan using mantis to trap
nanos in short-term paralysis so that
Tony like Oh be dead can claw away the
priceless weapon to eventually redirect
it against him and then an Iron Man -
Tony builds on his shortcomings from the
first film yet grades with a portable
version of his armor the mark-5 suitcase
but when that armor is vulnerable to
whiplashes electrical attacks Tony later
upgrades that version to absorb
electrical currents power 400% capacity
and then later an endgame stark again
uses that function ok Thor hit me in
Iron Man 2 Ivan Vanko also tells Tony if
you could make good lead people was used
to believe it and then an infinity war
Tony will later draw just a bit of blood
from Thanos to show that that God could
be killed and I remain - Tony learns the
value of his father's legacy that one
genius alone is limited by his time and
by whatever is in his box of scraps so
he must share his knowledge and Tony
Lawrence at the answers to the future
are often found in the past a lesson he
applies an endgame but Tony has a bit of
a less profound takeaway from these
events vanko's drone fleet strategy
little better when the events of the
Avengers scare him into wanting a suit
of armor around the world he responds an
age of Ultron with a Banco style
iron Legion drone fleet big mistake now
the mark 7 armour introduced in the
Avengers builds on the relatively slow
mark 5 suitcase with Rapid Deployment
capable of catching Tony in midair and
an Iron Man 3 Tony further builds on
that flexibility by making each piece of
his armor propulsive and by the end of
the movie making the arc reactor
separate from his flesh I think I'll be
back to age of Ultron so here Tony
introduces some awesome tech to address
a past problem Hulk's security with the
Merc 44 Hulkbuster but of course Tony's
iron Legion drones get hacked by Ultron
who then derives Tony's tech inserting
the mine stone in that process later
leads to vision but the key lesson that
start learns is that his tech and his
suits are not as important as a person
using that technology a lesson that he
passes on to Peter Parker in home comes
you're nothing without this shoot then
you shouldn't have it okay my dad
Captain America Civil War is a failure
for Tony he fails to rein in cap his
tech fails against ant-man he gets
Rhodey hurts but he starts to apply one
critical lesson legacy he realizes that
that younger generation of nerds like
Peter Parker
sometimes those kids are worth listening
to interesting with all the snow
maybe the kids understood that was
Tony's failure an Iron Man 3 he ignored
the nerdy fanboy aldrich killian until
he grew up into a threat which is a
lesson that that nerdy kid Harley keiner
helped him learn so in spider-man
homecoming Tony evolves into a teacher
he restrains Peter's suit with a
training wheels protocol and this of
course is after Nick Fury a Natasha
Romanov chastised Tony for letting
Rhodey pilot a suit with no restrictions
you let your friend fly away with you
soup Tony also installs warmers and
Peter soon after his mark two armored
pros uber in the first movie and after
he almost got hypothermia an Iron Man 3
Peter suit also comes with a GPS tracker
so that Peter wouldn't get lost in
foreign countries like Tony did and that
brings us to the biggest leap forward in
Tony's armor in infinity war now yes it
has been a bit of a struggle to keep
these daily doses of distraction coming
at you from the blue dungeon mark 2 you
don't know this but these blue surfaces
are endothermic they like suck my energy
anyway the best way to keep my energy up
is with a bang energy thanks to bang
energy for sponsoring this video every
can of bang is 16 ounces that's right
there's no wimpy 12 ounce cans here it
contains that 300 milligrams of caffeine
and sugar free in a zero calories yet it
tastes great there are over 20 different
flavors to choose from in one of those
great flavors is lack cherry vanilla get
that hint of vanilla you get the hint of
cherry dark blackness that gives you a
deeper energy to fight whatever giant
blue organism you're living in check out
bang on Instagram you can get 25% off
your order at bank - energy calm when
you use the code new rock stars 25 there
you can buy cans of bang energy
including their sweet tea flavor their
key to coffee flavor they're sour Head
flavored all their flavors pretty good
in their own ways you can also get
clothing fitness supplements and all
kinds of stuff to be your best bang self
thanks you gonna bang energy for
sponsoring this video get 25% off at
bang - energy calm using the code new
rock stars 25 and follow the creator of
bang on instagram at bang Energy CEO
okay so in Infinity Ward Tony introduces
the mark 50 armor which has bunch of
cool stuff including an additional
rocket booster to his thrusters so that
he can quickly catch up to Peter on the
key ship after he was unable to catch up
the Rodian Civil War but really the cool
part here is the nanotech I need BOTS
that lock into place as seamless armor
closing the gaps after ant-man
drunk down between the plates of his
armor Tony also equips himself with
melee weapons after losing the melee
with cap and Bucky but Tony also
upgrades Peters suit into the iron
spider armor with pressurized oxygen
flow for high altitude after Peter
struggled against the airborne villain
vulture Tony also gives Peter for
additional armored arms Waldo's after
you know Peter could have used a few
extra hands keeping that berry from
splitting apart in homecoming and then
when we catch up to him an endgame Tony
has managed to survive weeks on the
Benatar with nebula they did have some
food supplies but it's possible we got
some of his drinking water from himself
back in Iron Man 2 he revealed a new
urinary filtration system just keyed I
know it has a filtration system you
could drink that worth the time Knights
an endgame showed that Tony was so aware
of each generation of his past upgrades
that he knew that in 2012 his mark 7
armor did not yet have the mark 15
nanobot going inside you so an old
version ant-man could still slip in
there and he knew that his arc reactor
was still attached to his heart because
this was before Iron Man 3 so that he
could go into cardiac arrest to
something happen but he knew that this
suit could still sustain an electric
shock so Thor's love tap wouldn't kill
him and so Tony's final in-game arc 85
armor applied everything he learned
including the process that created
vision fusing his tech with Infinity
stones his new stark tech gauntlet fixed
his failure to claw the gauntlet off
Thanos on Titan by using nanotech to
absorb the stones from one part of his
armor to another so ultimately Tony came
full circle with what he described as
the perfect weapon all the way back in
this first film appearance they say the
best weapon is when you never have to
fire I respectfully disagree I prefer
the weapon you only have to fire once
and so Tony Stark finally built the
weapon that he only had to fire once but
as geniuses Stark was he still left this
world with plenty of oversights you try
to leave Peter Parker with the perfect
tech for a superhero who would need a
heads-up display in plain sight since at
that point the world still didn't know
Peter was a superhero but Tony's failure
to appreciate the power of his own
hollow tech left Peter susceptible to
emotional manipulation via illusions by
ex Stark employees and there's also room
to improve on Tony's tech that could
tell us how we will see the tech news
next in the MCU
really
fatal flaw of Tony's final suit is that
it's well they don't he died in it
so one improvement on this tech is
protection from cosmic mysticism and
radiation the 10 rings is coming back in
MCU and shang-chi and they wanted Tony's
weaponry for a reason which I believe
could be to wield the alien Makluan
magic of the ten rings
Tony's leftover nano tech gauntlet could
be useful it improved to protect the
wielder we also know that Marvel's
artists have drawn up visuals for the
iron mage Doctor Strange in the Iron Man
armor which in the comics is derived
from Victor Von Doom a man of science
and a man of magic as brilliant as Tony
Stark was he knew nothing about magic or
mystical energy he was limited by the
technology of his timeline and as we
expand into a multiverse there is a room
for all kind of geniuses to learn how to
spark that magic into its creations
Peter Parker Victor Von Doom Stephen
strange the ten rings
Cherie Harley keiner Nate Richards iron
lad or of course his daughter Morgan now
a reminder that you can join our
infinity Saga watch along twice a week
with us on discord by becoming a patron
of new rock stars at patreon.com slash
new rock stars
comment down below follow me at EA vos
follow new rock stars and subscribed in
rock searcher breakdowns of everything
you love thanks for watching bye
[Music]